today marks two weeks since the death of
george floyd
massive nationwide protest are showing
no signs of slowing down and now there
are calls all around the country
to defund police departments amid
demonstrations in minneapolis where
floyd was killed
a majority of city council members
announced plans to dismantle the
department there
in favor of a new system of public
safety they did not say though what that
may look like
the city's mayor does not support the
idea and he was booed during a weekend
rally
in washington today democratic lawmakers
are expected to introduce legislation
that would overhaul
police departments across the country
among the changes it would ban the use
of chokeholds
to subdue suspects and make it easier to
prosecute officers
for police brutality
attorney general william barr told face
to nation yesterday that he believes
systemic racism is not a problem in u.s
law enforcement
congresswoman val demings who used to be
orlando's police chief calls it the
ghost in the room
the florida democrat is on the short
list of potential running mates for
presumptive presidential nominee joe
biden and congresswoman demings joins us
now
from orlando congresswoman good morning
a lot of news to get to i want to start
with the news out of minneapolis uh
the city council voting to dismantle not
just
defund but dismantle and rebuild the
police department there
is that a strategy you could agree with
well first of all let me say good
morning to you and everyone it's good to
be
uh with you there are a lot of things
being proposed throughout the nation and
i think it's the direct result of people
being
hurt disappointed at what happened to mr
floyd
that's all too familiar to them but also
angry and demanding change and i do
believe that
everyone has a right to look at any
proposal
that is put forth because there
desperately needs to
be changed i i also believe that the
council is being very thoughtful
in terms of looking at all of the
services that police provide
you know there are some cases that
statutorily law enforcement is
responsible for
investigating they do a lot of things
associated with natural disasters and
terrorism
and so what i believe the council along
with
law enforcement authorities and other
community leaders will sit down
and look at everything and come out with
the plan that allows them to keep
minneapolis safe but also
bring the community and the police
together in a much needed and long
overdue way
yeah so congresswoman you mentioned the
context there and you also mentioned
that there are statutes that call police
into situations where a badge and a gun
may not be necessary
so on the on the question of defunding
the police what many people mean is move
that money
out of law enforcement hands and into
another sort of community engagement
fund
do you support that strategy
you know as i've listened to what has
occurred and watched what has occurred
certainly
over the last two weeks what happened to
mr floyd
there is no one on planet earth i hope
that believes anything about that
situation should have happened a lot
went wrong there but i'm also reminded
of the words of former chief david brown
out of dallas texas
when he had five of his officers
executed and he said something to this
effect that
every time society fails the police are
called in to
fix it and we all know usually by the
time the police are called
something has already gone drastically
wrong
within society and look as a former law
enforcement officer and as a police
chief
i know that the police are pulled to
respond to
situations on the street and in
communities that they are not prepared
to respond to
and not trained quite frankly to respond
to while they have received
several amounts of training and critical
incident debriefing dealing with mental
health
persons who are suffering from mental
health issues i do believe there is
opportunity here for the police and the
community to
come together and kind of spread look at
the responsibilities things that police
are taking on
that they were never supposed to take on
in the first place
and come out with a better plan
congresswoman
yeah it sounds like you're not using the
words defund the police but in terms of
narrowing the scope of the police
mission it sounds like you do agree that
that could be
in the future of this country i want to
talk about the bigger future of this
country and the past attorney general
barr
says systemic racism is not present in
law enforcement other administrative
administration officials have said the
same thing how can you fix a problem
that
roughly half the leadership does not
recognize exists
well you know i've said it multiple
times
long before the tragedy that happened
with mr floyd that racism
is and continues to be the ghost in the
room and look
i hear what uh attorney general barr is
saying
i don't believe he believes that i
believe that is just a talking point and
unfortunately
when you fail to publicly admit that
there is a problem
then it is extremely difficult to
address the problem and i've also said
that the president and certainly the top
cop i.e
william barr have a direct
responsibility to intervene
and say that yes we have a problem but
we're going to put the full weight
of the white house and the department of
justice to
fixing it to ride in it and to showing
compassion
and bringing the country together
unfortunately i don't believe the
president nor the attorney general have
the capability of doing that and
certainly
if they are continuing to stand at the
microphone on a public and international
stage
and say there is no problem then quite
frankly i think that they have served
their usefulness
for this country congresswoman demings
we we do have to go but i can't let you
go without asking you have you spoken
to former vice president joe biden
lately and what has he said
well i'm not going to share any personal
conversations that i have or had not
i have not had with the vice president
but look i am absolutely honored to be
considered
to run along uh side joe biden and i'll
leave it there
okay all right neither confirming or
denying the conversations are underway
congresswoman val demings very well done
uh
thank you very much we'll have to leave
it there